when 9 11 took place  we thought world war iii is  starting do you know what happened after  9 11. no one cared if you're white or  black  you can't find your kid i'll come help  you wait you're white you're not  supposed to help me who said  dude i don't care where's your kid i'm  coming to help you out people were  signing up in the military for the hell  of it saying no one does something like  this to my country i'm going to go after  the enemy we were proud americans  proud red white and blue i'm an american  are you a republican no i'm an american  are you democrat no i'm an american  kovat hits you know what we started  saying kobe that's people stop saying  i'm an american i'm a democrat  i'm a republican i'm a dis [ __ ]  you're an american first enough for this  politics style  we're americans first and i don't care  what anybody says